bitcoin
is fueled by technology called the
blockchain or blockchain technology
whatever it is what the [ __ ] is the
blockchain
i need to know what this is how he keeps
laughing you don't you don't know let it
go
yeah so uh let's start with blockchain
technology yeah blockchain technology
was created to solve a problem called
the double spin problem so you gotta
understand the problem to understand the
solution if uh i create uh music and i
put it out in a digital format it's a
music file right you have the music file
and you're listening to [ __ ] you're like
damn pop is a [ __ ] banger yeah andrew
wants it he's like yo send me the song
you hit send when you hit send the
computer program creates a copy sends
him the song he's now listening to my
song but you still have my song as well
you both can listen you're both happy
you're like yo we can listen to the cool
song right but you and you don't know
who has the original and who has the
copy all you know is you got a file you
got a file that's fine when it's music
that's fine when it's a photo that's
fine when it's all these things that it
doesn't matter about scarcity but with
money
if i have a [ __ ] digital dollar and
you say send me the dollar and i send
you it and now you got it and i got it
well who's got the dollar who's got the
real who's got the counterfeit we don't
know and so there's been a bunch of
people over the years who have tried to
create digital currency but this has
been the big problem is the file can be
replicated easily and you can't prove
what the original is
so that's called a double spin problem
he could send it to you and then send it
to me and we both think we got the
dollar but actually we just got copies
and he still has the dollar
seems like a problem isn't this how
banking works to a certain extent
let's not go there but i i don't want to
spend too much time but isn't that the
whole idea of like if the bank only
needs to keep ten percent of the
reserves
in the bank and there's a hundred
thousand dollars can't you lend out 90
to him and now you just made 190 well
you just made whatever you thousand
dollars out of nowhere so there's
leverage there's all this complexity but
basically what they're doing in that
situation is they're not creating new
currency what they're doing is they're
bar they're borrowing it or you're
depositing it with them and they're
lending it on the back end and they're
doing all this stuff but technically is
it your money is it an iou that they
have you've made more out of nowhere
no because you gave them some money then
there's leverage they can borrow they
can do all this stuff the key to this is
counterfeit versus original i understand
that right i understand i just i just
think that the idea of like printing
money isn't that novel because like if
you're if you're oh banks want to be
central banks we can get into that no no
no no no let's keep saying but like
let's say i give you a hundred thousand
dollars to keep in your bank your bank
of america and he wants a loan you could
give him ninety thousand dollars to my
hundred thousand dollars but i can get
my hundred thousand whenever i want and
he can get his 90 whenever he wants you
just made 90 000 out of nowhere so when
you give me the money a lot of people
don't know this it's not your money
anymore
what
when you deposit the money in the bank
it's not your money they they have an
iou they owe you a hundred thousand
dollars but technically it's their money
now oh [ __ ] oh yeah yeah you pump all
right let's get back to blockchain ready
okay so that's a fact so so you're ready
yeah that's fact so look here's the
whole idea of a blockchain is uh if we
sit down and uh so blockchain verifies
the original
at a very high level but here's how it
works let's say we go to play monopoly
it's the best way to describe it four of
us sit down to play monopoly and uh with
monopoly there's a bank and then each of
us have the money in the game and we set
it out in front of us right and the way
the reason why monopoly works is because
as we are doing transactions you owe him
money bam i see you hand them the 200 he
hands me the money right all the stuff
we don't need a fifth person to stand
over us and act as the banker or the
centralized entity who does all the
transactions because there's full
transparency right if you ever play with
a kid and they put the money under the
table you're like yo get that [ __ ] up
here like i don't know what the [ __ ]
you're doing but i don't trust you right
so when the money's
uh transparently put on the table and
then all the transactions happen in
front of everybody we all don't have to
trust
that it's being done correctly we can
verify it i saw you give them the 200
yeah yeah yeah so a blockchain basically
is if we were playing that game and we
had a piece of paper and i wrote down
every transaction right i said you know
i gave andrew two hundred dollars right
you here dude so it's a ledger ledger
but every 10 minutes i ripped off the
piece of paper and i put it to the side
i said all right that was the first 10
minutes of the game that's all the
transactions that happened and then all
of a sudden we say played for the next
10 minutes started a new piece of paper
did it again bam done i rip off that
piece i stack it on top of the first 10
minutes we keep playing we've been
playing for 15 minutes now there's five
pieces of paper sitting over here and
you go you know what i think that you
owe me 30 dollars i said no actually in
minute 32 let me go back to the
transactions and i can show you that i
gave you that 30 already
that's essentially what a blockchain
does but rather than it be on paper what
it does is every 10 minutes it takes all
of the transactions that happen on the
block on the bitcoin network and it
basically puts it into a block so it's
literally just to give it almost like in
an overgeneralized way uh uh excel file
right of all the transactions and then
there's people who run the network they
validate yep looks good and as long as
more than 51 of people validate it they
chain
the block of transactions to the last
one and it goes all the way back to the
beginning so from january 3rd 2009 you
can go back on a blockchain and see
every single transaction that's ever
happened in this network
so it's literally
blocks
of transactions that are chained
together
bitcoin block attack